Pardon me?
NOTE CONF
The community like me.
So one thing that's happened in the last 10 years
NOTE CONF
of university teaching is that we've gone from doing a
lot of courses that were designed like this one.
NOTE CONF
And maybe it might be familiar to you if you
did Comp 2000.
NOTE CONF
It's got a similar design moved away from courses like
that more towards courses where, uh, partly because of how
NOTE CONF
people learn and how the technology is available.
These days, uh, you can dip in and learn something
NOTE CONF
and then dip out and dip in and learn something
and dip out.
NOTE CONF
And that's definitely well, definitely I'm not in your generation,
but from my position.
NOTE CONF
That's definitely better for people, uh, who are coming to
our classes.
NOTE CONF
So let's just put a generation label on for your
generation.
NOTE CONF
It's a bit, uh, a more effective way for you
to engage with material.
NOTE CONF
But there does reach a point where it's not a
way that works anymore and that the material graduates beyond
NOTE CONF
that style of learning.
And so, with Com 3000, we made a conscious decision
NOTE CONF
that while we know people are less comfortable with that
style, this is the place that has to happen.
NOTE CONF
Or at least this and a few other places.
So what I'm trying to get across is that we're
NOTE CONF
sympathetic to the, um, situation you're in.
We want to hear about it.
NOTE CONF
We wanna help you progress.
But at the same time, we've all got to agree
NOTE CONF
that we're actually targeting that other way of engaging with
material.
NOTE CONF
We're actually saying Ah, so that that my previous way
of engaging with material the drop in, drop out, pick
NOTE CONF
up little bits here, pick up little bits there, which
works and worked for me isn't the way for Comp
NOTE CONF
3000.
Um, and that might be a real hassle for some
NOTE CONF
of you because it might be the only way you
like to engage with material.
NOTE CONF
And that might be a relief for others of you
who find that hasn't worked for them in the past.
NOTE CONF
But either way, I wanna be explicit that we are
aware that that's a transition.
NOTE CONF
We're trying to support that transition, and little talks like
this are my way of Of of doing that, I'll
NOTE CONF
just get up to Echo 3.
60.
NOTE CONF
Look in.
This is my fourth time logging into Ireland this morning
NOTE CONF
and the first time I haven't had to do the
T two FA one.
NOTE CONF
You have to show me how to do two FA
on my computer.
NOTE CONF
I've heard you can do it, but I'm an old
man and I don't even know how to do it
NOTE CONF
on my phone.
Um, I'm I'm sick of I'm gonna carry my phone
NOTE CONF
around with me.
Um uh and so, yeah, I'm really appreciative of anyone
NOTE CONF
who comes to me and explains their experience.
Even if I then feel like I'm telling you, you
NOTE CONF
should be doing something else.
I am actually quite appreciative.
NOTE CONF
So, like in particular, that response there, um, and the
meta programming is no surprise.
NOTE CONF
Absolutely expected.
No matter Anybody, under any circumstances with any study, history
NOTE CONF
would come in and hit meta programming and just go
W.
NOTE CONF
That's fine.
Uh, brain bending moments are good.
NOTE CONF
Uh, even when they're difficult.
Yeah, that's true.
NOTE CONF
No video yet.
I haven't pressed the button.
NOTE CONF
I don't know how announcements get delivered to you, but
I did pop up an announcement saying we were starting
NOTE CONF
at 9.
15.
NOTE CONF
But I know some of you get them digested and
a bunch of stuff so these people wouldn't have realised.
NOTE CONF
Um I just decided on the drive in.
I'll just tell everyone we're starting at 9.
NOTE CONF
15.
Why is this not projecting?
NOTE CONF
Everything's on people online.
Can't see a video either.
NOTE CONF
Uh, because this is not doing its thing.
Yes, it is doing its thing.
NOTE CONF
It's just not coming up anyway.
Need it?
NOTE CONF
You're entering power saver mode.
You're plugged in, you're plugged in.
NOTE CONF
I've been using these things for 15 years.
Why isn't this one working?
NOTE CONF
OK, so we can project the internal screen, but we
can't predict the laptop screen.
NOTE CONF
Alright, that's a massive hassle.
This dongle has always been a pain in the arse.
NOTE CONF
Excuse my language.
There we go.
NOTE CONF
Two unlabeled HDM I ports, and you've got to pick
the right one.
NOTE CONF
Ok, so to follow up on that, um, the I'm
being judgmental.
NOTE CONF
Here.
You excuse me being judgmental?
NOTE CONF
No, cos it's my way of being effective.
So if this doesn't apply to you, just go doesn't
NOTE CONF
apply to me.
Matt's being judgmental.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the thing I think a lot of people are
missing is the setting aside of a block of time
NOTE CONF
where you hide yourself from other distractions and you just
dig into the material without expectations, without outcomes, without physically
NOTE CONF
doing anything, you start.
You let the material wash over you a little bit
NOTE CONF
and then go back and do a second round where
things are actually happening.
NOTE CONF
I'm typing in code.
I'm doing things I'm trying techniques.
NOTE CONF
Um, again, Theoretically, no.
No evidence to back this up.
NOTE CONF
But the fact that I I see myself doing this
right, the fact that I can now go and find
NOTE CONF
someone giving me an explicit explanation of how something works
on the Internet and I can then copy their explanation
NOTE CONF
M mirror their movements and learn that way is very,
uh, appealing.
NOTE CONF
And then you get to topics where that won't fly
and you're left kind of tool less.
NOTE CONF
So this is what I'm trying to tell you is
that the way to learn in those circumstances is to
NOTE CONF
do something you might not have done before, which is
the reason we're focusing.
NOTE CONF
We're obsessing about these textbooks and just banging on about
them all the time is just sit with the book.
NOTE CONF
I've got my iPad so that I can do it
with an iPad.
NOTE CONF
We've got at least a couple of copies in the
library, so if you want a paper copy, you can
NOTE CONF
borrow one from the library.
But you just sit there and you just read the
NOTE CONF
book and yeah, you're not understanding it anywhere near as
well or or anywhere near the same way as your
NOTE CONF
understanding material that you're used to interacting with.
Um, but I think that's the missing piece cos I
NOTE CONF
had to go back to that.
Me, even I had to go back to that meta
NOTE CONF
programming.
I had to read over it, top to bottom, get
NOTE CONF
the full story of what the heck he was talking
about in that chapter and then go back.
NOTE CONF
And I could make sense out of each part as
it came up.
NOTE CONF
But by visiting just each part one at a time,
I got to the meta programming and it just looked
NOTE CONF
like it came out of the blue and had nowhere
to go, and I didn't understand what it was about.
NOTE CONF
So I guess I'm suggesting you move from understanding small
chunks at a time and building each chunk, you move
NOTE CONF
to a different technique or an adjustment of that technique
where you you look, you understand a whole chunk at
NOTE CONF
a shallow level, and then you understand a whole chunk
at a deeper level and then a deeper level than
NOTE CONF
a deeper level.
OK, alright, so we're trying to make sure that you're
NOTE CONF
tooled up.
The other part of that, of course, is that workshops
NOTE CONF
just don't work.
Uh, it seems pretty clear to me, although I don't
NOTE CONF
have the metrics to show it.
So it's pretty clear to me that a tonne of
NOTE CONF
people, not you obviously a tonne of people are turning
up to the workshop classes, not having watched the lectures.
NOTE CONF
That's just not gonna fly because, like I said, you
need to see the whole story before the individual parts
NOTE CONF
can make sense.
And so we're presenting a chunk of the story in
NOTE CONF
the lectures.
And if you're skipping that and turning up to the
NOTE CONF
workshops and you going well, I've got to do the
first work.
NOTE CONF
None of it's gonna make any sense to you and
your workshop teachers not gonna be able to explain it
NOTE CONF
cos what you need is that two hour talk that
I gave, but nobody listened to to make the context.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and that's a technique that has worked in the
past for many of you.
NOTE CONF
Because, as I say, it was the the small individual
task where you were physically engaging with the activity that
NOTE CONF
fired the neurons and the synapses in the right way
to help you learn.
NOTE CONF
So it's your preference and your expectation for learning.
Um, but here it's So you're just gonna hit a
NOTE CONF
wall because none of the things you're doing are gonna
have any context to to make any sense.
NOTE CONF
OK, that's enough of that.
You you don't want to hear that because you're the
NOTE CONF
people who are turning up to my lecture and you
do all the right thing, but it never hurts.
NOTE CONF
It never hurts, because there's definitely been a big, big,
big change in how people assimilate information.
NOTE CONF
Since I sat in that seat in 1997 Um, and
I it's part of my job to try and understand
NOTE CONF
where you're coming from.
Uh, but it's part of your job to try and
NOTE CONF
understand where I'm coming from.
Let's get the notepad up for drawing.
NOTE CONF
But just as a very clear message to anybody who's
listening to the lecture later.
NOTE CONF
If you're listening to lectures after you've been to workshop
materials, expect everything to be a nightmare for you.
NOTE CONF
It just will.
The course is designed to make that horrible experience.
NOTE CONF
So I stopped doing it the other way around.
OK, so maybe we'll quickly skim over and put the
NOTE CONF
context together for last week's stuff.
Um, to explain where we're going.
NOTE CONF
And one criticism I have with this book is that
he started off with a bunch of great diagrams, and
NOTE CONF
then he kind of started to give up on great
diagrams.
NOTE CONF
So I've got to add a few of my own.
So I'm gonna use my notepad here.
NOTE CONF
I probably won't upload these.
I know everyone says, Can you upload the notepad that
NOTE CONF
you did in lectures?
No.
NOTE CONF
Why would I not do that?
Can somebody guess?
NOTE CONF
Well, I'd like to give you the choice of what
to do.
NOTE CONF
So the answer was because anyone watch the lectures.
But it's actually more that it's a very strong temptation
NOTE CONF
to skip the explanation and go to the solution.
And that just won't make any sense to you.
NOTE CONF
All I'm doing is incentivizing you to grab my final
answer and to try and reverse engineer my explanations and
NOTE CONF
you'll always get it wrong.
So I'm trying to incentivize you to actually listen to
NOTE CONF
the explanations, because then the final diagram makes sense.
But what that means is for people who were in
NOTE CONF
the lecture or whatever, who like I want a copy
of that.
NOTE CONF
Then you've probably gotta grab a copy before I finish.
Um, I'm telling you that before I start in case
NOTE CONF
you got to grab out a piece of paper or
something or people snap pictures of the screen, whatever.
NOTE CONF
I don't care to get a copy of something you
want to memorise that I'm drawing on my visualizer.
NOTE CONF
But of course it's in the recordings.
Anyway.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I only have one thing on the screen at
a time today, so I'm just gonna start off with
NOTE CONF
a bit of come a look at Oh, get it
on.
NOTE CONF
Take no med.
These things aren't great with we screened about.
NOTE CONF
I don't have paperwork.
Uh, and this gives me multiple colours, blah, blah, blah,
NOTE CONF
blah, blah.
All the good things.
NOTE CONF
What the Oh, no, that's right.
We go.
NOTE CONF
OK, so if we recall whoopsie If this is run
out of charge, I'm gonna be very annoyed.
NOTE CONF
Uh, sorry.
Might that look at this?
NOTE CONF
You used to just turn up with a box of
slides and a texter, and off you go now.
NOTE CONF
OK, so we we've gone from the situation.
I really want you to think of this interpreter as
NOTE CONF
a pipeline, and each step is translating from one form
to another.
NOTE CONF
So we saw that the scanner translated from characters into
tokens, and we invented these tokens ourselves.
NOTE CONF
I'll make this bigger.
Not that one.
NOTE CONF
So we invented these tokens ourselves, and he said that
anything that's a token is gonna have a special token
NOTE CONF
type.
It's probably got the string that the token originally was
NOTE CONF
built from.
Uh, it might have a literal attached to it if
NOTE CONF
it's a a number or a string, and it's got
a line that it came from.
NOTE CONF
Really.
All the action is in the token types.
NOTE CONF
Um, so these are all the different token types I
might see in my language, So I know I might
NOTE CONF
see the character a but that doesn't relate to a
particular token.
NOTE CONF
I know the character left parentheses does relate to a
particular token.
NOTE CONF
I know when I see ABC D in a space
that relates to a token called an identifier.
NOTE CONF
So every possible type of token I expect to see
gets its name in here.
NOTE CONF
And you can see that I've been doing some extensions
for various tasks that you might see in your workshops
NOTE CONF
to add some tokens that weren't in the original language.
That's the, uh, The scanner's job then was to take
NOTE CONF
the character stream and create a token stream or a
list of characters and create a list of tokens.
NOTE CONF
So he did that for us with this scan method,
Uh, so the M scanner M was for uh, the
NOTE CONF
scanner scans the tokens, and it spits out at the
end a list of tokens.
NOTE CONF
Very cool.
So we've got one that's one part of the process
NOTE CONF
happening now.
The next part was to turn that series of tokens
NOTE CONF
into something else.
And what was the something else we decided to turn
NOTE CONF
it into?
Or was it called an a ST, an abstract syntax
NOTE CONF
tree?
And just as before, we get to decide what that
NOTE CONF
abstract Syntex We made up the tokens.
How we controlled it.
NOTE CONF
Um, we can control what the A ST is gonna
look like too.
NOTE CONF
But they generally always look the same.
They have more of the structure of the programme in
NOTE CONF
them.
So we saw an a ST We made an a
NOTE CONF
ST and we wrote a pas.
We haven't written the pas yet that converts into the
NOTE CONF
A ST.
So we got to the point of saying I'm gonna
NOTE CONF
have to convert to an a ST.
What the heck do they look like?
NOTE CONF
And I better programme up my a ST.
So as a preview of what the A SC looks
NOTE CONF
like with the hope that my things starts working Oh,
yeah, you can see the pain.
NOTE CONF
OK, we'll try the next thing.
Doc, Come on.
NOTE CONF
Ah, a USB CD.
As you see, I've got everything else besides anyone got
NOTE CONF
a USB CD OS BC cable.
They can know we might be working with paper in
NOTE CONF
the end.
Anyway, I might have to borrow paper.
NOTE CONF
Um so we generate the Yeah, we wanna see what
this blooming I can see someone's whoop, but I can't
NOTE CONF
see my apple pencil.
Oh, there it is.
NOTE CONF
Can we connect?
I gotta plug it in.
NOTE CONF
Yay!
All right.
NOTE CONF
Success just to get my iPad to remember the apple
pencil that I could see this morning when I left
NOTE CONF
home.
The joys Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Thank you.
There it is.
NOTE CONF
And it's getting in touch.
OK, Ok, thank you.
NOTE CONF
All right, let's draw fine.
So we started off with our character stream.
NOTE CONF
Maybe we did one plus two.
That was our programme that got converted into a stream
NOTE CONF
of tokens.
So I'll use this square bracket notation for lists.
NOTE CONF
And that got turned into token integer one another token.
Plus another token.
NOTE CONF
Did you two?
Yeah, token list of tokens.
NOTE CONF
So the next thing we want to convert that into
is an abstract syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
And the abstract syntax tree actually is a representation.
Well, it looks like this.
NOTE CONF
It looks like actually, in our case, it looks like
so the ABX index actually looks like that.
NOTE CONF
So quite a bit more structure has been added into
it.
NOTE CONF
Hopefully you agree?
That's the structure you would have thought of in the
NOTE CONF
programme in the first place.
Ah, now this is not doesn't just come out of
NOTE CONF
nowhere cos what we did last week was build up
to why this abstract syntax tree has to look like
NOTE CONF
this because we introduced the ideas of the idea of
grammars for generating strings.
NOTE CONF
We did that last week, right?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
And then those grammars were tree like things.
We had a grandma.
NOTE CONF
So this grandma might have been something like an expression
is a expression operator expression or an expression by itself.
NOTE CONF
And an operator is a plus or a minus or
a star.
NOTE CONF
Expression can also be a literal and a literal is
a number or a string.
NOTE CONF
That's not exactly the grammar we looked at, but as
an example.
NOTE CONF
And that creates a tree like thing because this part
of the grammar has other parts of the grammar within
NOTE CONF
it.
So then we realise we're gonna have to create one
NOTE CONF
of these a STS.
And we could have just done that.
NOTE CONF
So we need some cla we had needed, uh, enumerations
to represent the integers.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna need classes to represent these things.
Just like if you do a linked list, you need
NOTE CONF
a class for the nodes.
When you do a tree, you need a class for
NOTE CONF
the internal nodes and the leaf nodes.
You would have done that before.
NOTE CONF
So we've got we're gonna have to have this so
somewhere we're gonna have to do something like glass binary
NOTE CONF
with, you know, maybe it's got a M token telling
me what it is.
NOTE CONF
Uh, operator, Oops.
A right to And so that tiny that semi class
NOTE CONF
definition matches this object that I drew up here.
It's a I can make objects of the class, but
NOTE CONF
anyway, they'll always have an operator inside them.
I can make objects of the class literal, and they'll
NOTE CONF
always have to have a number inside of in my
case, but it's probably actually be an object object value.
NOTE CONF
Um, but actually, the binary is gonna have to have
two other things, which is two other.
NOTE CONF
It's gonna have to point to the two literals.
So it's gonna have to have a literal left and
NOTE CONF
a little right to make the tree work.
Uh, and then I think to myself, none of these
NOTE CONF
can't be literals because what if I've got a plus?
B, I need to have a variable in there.
NOTE CONF
So I realise maybe that I need to have a
super class for them all.
NOTE CONF
And these all need to extend that class.
And so down here, I don't put literal literal.
NOTE CONF
I put EX PR EX PR.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
So I could go ahead and do this for the
abstract syntax tree that I wanna build, and it would
NOTE CONF
look like I just call it X.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
It would end up looking like this thing here, and
And we've used an extra java trick here, which is
NOTE CONF
to make all of the subclasses literally inner classes of
the other one.
NOTE CONF
But otherwise, we've really got this abstract class expression.
And then we've got my binary one that extends expression.
NOTE CONF
It's got a left and an operator and a right.
I've got my literal one that extends expression, and it's
NOTE CONF
got a value.
And there's a few others I realise I need.
NOTE CONF
I need a unary operator for something that doesn't take
two arguments.
NOTE CONF
I need a grouping operator for So when I've got
parenthesized things, um, are there any others I need?
NOTE CONF
No, I think that's it.
Uh, yes, I can see them down here, actually.
NOTE CONF
Binary grouping, literal unary.
Now I'll be able to build a tree from those.
NOTE CONF
Fair enough.
At this point, I could have just written this class
NOTE CONF
and moved on.
But by looking ahead in last week's material, you know
NOTE CONF
that when you're processing a tree like this, um, a
useful way to do it is with the visitor pattern.
NOTE CONF
So you see, why don't I just bake the visitor
pattern into this while I go and you learn what
NOTE CONF
the visitor pattern is?
The visitor pattern is, um everyone has to have an
NOTE CONF
accept method.
And when you visit, you call the accept method on
NOTE CONF
that object and the then you need to visit visit
an interface that does all of the specific methods that
NOTE CONF
you might have to do, and the rest works itself
out.
NOTE CONF
So maybe you go in by hand and you're like,
OK, well, these are gonna be visitors as well, so
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna put an accept method in them.
Um, each one needs an accept method, blah blah, blah,
NOTE CONF
blah, blah.
Now I start to realise I'm just writing the same
NOTE CONF
thing over and over again.
But I've only had to do it for 44 classes
NOTE CONF
here.
It's not a big deal, but later on, we're gonna
NOTE CONF
have to do it for like, 21 courses So at
this point, the author stopped and said, I'm not gonna
NOTE CONF
write this class by hand.
I'm gonna write a programme that writes this class for
NOTE CONF
me so that later on, when I've got 21 in
there, I'm not busting my butt and putting in lots
NOTE CONF
of errors.
And that's where we turn to the meta programming just
NOTE CONF
to build this one class with it's nested classes.
That's gonna be useful for us.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so we took a stop and a detour on
how meta programming might work and wrote an entire separate
NOTE CONF
tool.
It's not it.
NOTE CONF
It's not actually a part of my interpreter at all.
It's just a tool that generates code for my interpreter
NOTE CONF
called Generate a ST, and its only job was to
generate one of those EX PR classes with all of
NOTE CONF
the inner classes that I needed.
And so to do that, I found a way to
NOTE CONF
ride out all the inner classes that I needed.
What the heck is that doing?
NOTE CONF
Sometimes I don't like ID E sport.
Um, I found a way to write out in a
NOTE CONF
summarised way, all of the inner classes that I needed,
and then I ran a script over that to create
NOTE CONF
that expression class and spit it out ready for the
rest of my compiler to use.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, And so that meta programming thing is funny.
I'm gonna draw it to try and help it Make
NOTE CONF
more sense.
You've never done this before.
NOTE CONF
As far as I know in your study, it's super
powerful and very important.
NOTE CONF
So it's like a key outcome of a course like
this is to be out of meta programming.
NOTE CONF
So let's think more about exactly what happened from a
diagrammatic point of view, I Sorry.
NOTE CONF
I was looking at code and talking about it when
it wasn't there.
NOTE CONF
So sorry, I'll go back and do that because you
might have been lost.
NOTE CONF
Um, this was the class we were trying to build
that matched the the binary tree we had.
NOTE CONF
So it had a single binary tree node with the
the operations I expected, and it had a single literal
NOTE CONF
node with the one I expected and then some other
ones as well.
NOTE CONF
And the visitor class was included.
Like I said, I could write this by hand.
NOTE CONF
I might make some errors as I write it, but
I could just write it by hand, but instead we
NOTE CONF
generated this one class file.
So my the that my final product looked like had
NOTE CONF
my directory into which I put my own code right.
And in there I had a scanner and I had
NOTE CONF
another one.
I had an M locks dot java.
NOTE CONF
I had various dot Java files that were getting the
job done and talking.
NOTE CONF
There were more, but this will do.
And what I needed was an EX PR dot java
NOTE CONF
that had the superclass expression, the subclass, binary, the subclass
literal, the subclass grouping the subclass, you know.
NOTE CONF
So instead of writing it by hand, I wrote a
whole another programme whose job is to generate that for
NOTE CONF
him.
So now to create my interpreter, I can't just compile
NOTE CONF
my Java files.
I have to run this tool.
NOTE CONF
I wrote to get the last Java file.
Then I can compile my Java files and then I
NOTE CONF
can run my interpreter So meta programming because this is
a programme that creates that generates a programme and it
NOTE CONF
doesn't do much.
It really just generates the string and spits it out
NOTE CONF
into the file for you.
But that's what it does.
NOTE CONF
Fine to that.
I think the key reason to do that here is
NOTE CONF
actually just that the amount of boilerplate you end up
putting in with the the, uh, boilerplate being code.
NOTE CONF
It's always the same.
Every time with the visitor pattern makes meta programming pay
NOTE CONF
off.
Once you get to the bigger version.
NOTE CONF
Questions, I need questions to keep me moving in a
direction that's useful might be a question.
NOTE CONF
Sorry, but they're all good questions.
People considering NR functions that functions as as this moves
NOTE CONF
on deep.
No, right, it will still work.
NOTE CONF
So the question was, If I've got I've only got
binary and unary operators here, what happens when I get
NOTE CONF
the functions that can take any number of arguments?
The way he's broken it up is we're only doing
NOTE CONF
expressions in this chapter, and we do statements later a
function call and a function definition of the statement.
NOTE CONF
So he's avoided having to deal with that just yet,
because the only operators in a language only things that
NOTE CONF
appear in expressions are plus minus times and maybe divide
and the not, um so we've got a fixed set
NOTE CONF
that we know what to do with when we move
to functions?
NOTE CONF
Yes, we will have to have another type of we
get over here.
NOTE CONF
We'll find that we probably can't use binary unary.
We've probably got another fun.
NOTE CONF
Uh, probably another square called function core.
Uh, and that's got a list of Children instead of
NOTE CONF
just one child, Uh, instead of just a fixed number
of Children.
NOTE CONF
But yeah, it extends to that just fine.
Uh, yeah.
NOTE CONF
And that's why his notation over here.
So you gotta make sure I'm keeping if you see
NOTE CONF
me typing Well, looking at my computer without switching over
tell me.
NOTE CONF
And that's why his notation over here is It will
allow for that he'll eventually be able to put in
NOTE CONF
something like Function, which takes a list of EX PR,
which is pers.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, and he'll be able to generate a A class
for that straight away.
NOTE CONF
OK, I'm just gonna go back over last week to
see if there's anything else in particular I want to
NOTE CONF
get into.
Uh, I gotta go up the hard way or this
NOTE CONF
way previous.
OK, so there's our our abstract syntax tree is our
NOTE CONF
context free grammars which were ways of representing the string,
generating the string.
NOTE CONF
It goes well and then we went through the various
rules for how context free grammars work.
NOTE CONF
So the key I want you to remember here, though,
is that that context free grammar I'm doing it was
NOTE CONF
introduced because that's how you can describe all the valid
programmes.
NOTE CONF
OK?
And you need to have a way to describe all
NOTE CONF
the valid programmes because you need to have a way
to say this is a valid programme and this is
NOTE CONF
not a valid programme.
And he talked a bit about how it comes back
NOTE CONF
from history trying to trying to have a formal definition
for written languages which doesn't work.
NOTE CONF
Uh and then we built on context free grammars to
to make them better.
NOTE CONF
And then he gave us a context grammar for just
the locks, expressions, not any other part of the language.
NOTE CONF
So these are just single things that evaluate to a
value.
NOTE CONF
So no function calls, no sequencing.
None of that, um and then finally, how to make
NOTE CONF
that expression class.
It's gonna do all the hard work for us via
NOTE CONF
the meta programming, which was a whole, like whole thing.
OK, so the workshop task where we just said just
NOTE CONF
meta programme a main method A hello world was a
super simple meta programme because we recognised that.
NOTE CONF
You know, the whole idea of meta programming is confusing
at this point and the visitor pattern again.
NOTE CONF
A lot to think about just to understand why we're
doing it that way.
NOTE CONF
But it'll it'll keep coming back again because every time
we do something on abstract Syntex tree, we're gonna do
NOTE CONF
the visit of the patent.
The abstract Syntex tree ends up being the central data
NOTE CONF
structure.
So we've done character streams tokens and pretty much thrown
NOTE CONF
them away and moved on straight away to the abstract.
We're not gonna throw away the abstract Syntex tree so
NOTE CONF
fast.
That's the the top of the mountain part.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna We were doing all the action.
OK, so the last hour we were at is going
NOTE CONF
the other direction.
Last week we learnt what grammars are in the context
NOTE CONF
of generating strings.
This week we're gonna use grammars to go backwards from
NOTE CONF
the programme source token stream to the A ST or
to the grammar.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but we're gonna be representing that grammar underneath as
an a ST.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, that's from the token stream back to the grammar.
So we already saw a few examples where there were
NOTE CONF
two ways to generate the same string from a grammar.
What really the same token string from a grammar?
NOTE CONF
That's what we call ambiguity.
And that was not a problem when we were generating
NOTE CONF
strings, because our goal was to generate a string.
But if we're going backwards from the generated string to
NOTE CONF
what generated it and there's two possible ways to go
backwards, how do we know which one to take?
NOTE CONF
So that gets explored here.
The bottom line is that the ambiguity is bad and
NOTE CONF
you've got to get rid of it.
It's bad for the Parsa, but it's also bad for
NOTE CONF
the person programming.
The person programming has to know you.
NOTE CONF
You've you've been programming with a STS your whole life
without realising it in your head.
NOTE CONF
That's really what's been going on every time you work
out precedence rules and that kind of stuff you you're
NOTE CONF
building a little abstract syntax tree in your head.
You've been doing it since they taught you pem DS
NOTE CONF
at school, see what I mean, which is why we
can do lots of examples with, um, just numbers.
NOTE CONF
So when you did that in school, you were taught
that you should do one plus three first to get
NOTE CONF
a four and then you should do four plus four
next to get an A, and you should do a
NOTE CONF
plus five first to get a 13.
Not that that makes a difference here.
NOTE CONF
But if you add divisions that will make a difference.
Well, that was a construction of the you in your
NOTE CONF
head constructed what would have been the abstract Syntex tree.
For this.
NOTE CONF
It would have looked like you constructed that in your
head and realised that well, you can't do this one
NOTE CONF
yet.
You can't do this one yet, but you can do
NOTE CONF
this one, and so you do it and get a
four.
NOTE CONF
Ah, now I can do this one, so I do
it and I get an eight.
NOTE CONF
Ah, now I can do this one, so I do
it and get it.
NOTE CONF
13th in programming, we just take that to its logical
conclusion and do it for everything.
NOTE CONF
And you've been doing the same.
When you see something like maybe you see, if X
NOTE CONF
equals five S and Y equals six, you would have
created in your head an abstract syntax tree that had
NOTE CONF
the If up here, let's just put a piece of
code in here.
NOTE CONF
Return with return attached to it and then a condition
over here.
NOTE CONF
And you would have realised that the condition has two
parts and that you can't do the ICANN until you've
NOTE CONF
done the two equals.
And that one was X and five.
NOTE CONF
And this one was Y and six.
This was without You didn't draw this in your head.
NOTE CONF
But you did this grouping in your head.
You went.
NOTE CONF
I've gotta do that one first, then I've gotta do
this one.
NOTE CONF
Now that I've done those two, then I can do
this one.
NOTE CONF
Once I've worked that out, then I can do the
if.
NOTE CONF
Ok, so all we're doing here is explicitly putting into
the A structure That and the structure we need is
NOTE CONF
an abstract syntax tree.
And the abstract syntax tree is built so that the
NOTE CONF
things done later are at the top and the things
done earlier are at the leaves.
NOTE CONF
So the ambiguity was resolved, the the possible ambiguity here,
depending on your grammar might have been that this should
NOTE CONF
have looked like, uh, plus, uh, what am I looking
for here?
NOTE CONF
Uh, I'm I'm struggling with it because it's so wrong.
One plus three plus four.
NOTE CONF
Fine.
Uh, that's another way to interpret that, which is the
NOTE CONF
wrong way.
But based on the grammar from last year, uh, last
NOTE CONF
week, we're getting things that could go either way.
And we want to get rid of that ambiguity so
NOTE CONF
that we get just one, and it's the one we're
actually expecting.
NOTE CONF
And so this is why I say it's important.
Not just the parsa needs ambiguity gone because the Parsa
NOTE CONF
needs to make a decision.
The human needs the ambiguity gone because the human needs
NOTE CONF
the computer to do the same thing that they're gonna
do when they do it in their head.
NOTE CONF
OK, so this was the grammar we got left with.
And this grammar has all of those ambiguities in it.
NOTE CONF
Um, there are the two different ways I can generate.
Uh oh.
NOTE CONF
So this I'm looking at, let me just jump over
to it, then see it.
NOTE CONF
This is the grammar we got left with uh, at
the end of the last week and we we were
NOTE CONF
happily generating strings with that, but to give an example
of generating, it's gonna be a bit hard to have
NOTE CONF
both on the board this time.
So people on inside will get the bonus of having
NOTE CONF
both on the screen.
Everyone else has to switch to the the visualizer.
NOTE CONF
Um, so if I've got oh, if I've got one
plus two and I wanna generate that from this grammar,
NOTE CONF
how do I do it?
So whenever I generate something from a grammar, I start
NOTE CONF
at the top.
So it's always gotta be expression expression can generate a
NOTE CONF
literal unary binary or grouping.
I've really only got one choice here.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna have to generate a binary cos I can
look ahead and I can see that, Um, I know
NOTE CONF
that a binary can expand to it can only expand
the one thing which is expression, operator expression.
NOTE CONF
But I've done them vertically like that, cos I'm gonna
expand each one, and in this case I'm pretty sure
NOTE CONF
my operator's gonna be a plus, and the expression is
gonna expand to literal little room and one and two
NOTE CONF
so That's how I generated that string.
By going backwards through the generation, I end up with
NOTE CONF
the tree that I saw before.
If I just pull out the interesting parts, that's the
NOTE CONF
tree I drew before a plus with a So the
grammar actually is guiding me towards the tree.
NOTE CONF
And as we saw last week, if I did instead
one plus two plus three, I would all of a
NOTE CONF
sudden have two possible derivations leading to two possible treats.
So we've got to remove the ambiguity that allows those
NOTE CONF
two.
I won't write it out because it's too long.
NOTE CONF
Uh, we're gonna remove the ambiguity that would lead to
those two different derivations slash two different trees.
NOTE CONF
Where does the ambiguity come from?
In this case, the ambiguity is coming from this place
NOTE CONF
right here.
When we expand out something binary, we can choose whether
NOTE CONF
the expression on the left is the complicated one that's
got, uh, other operators inside it, or the one on
NOTE CONF
the right is the complicated one with other operators inside
it.
NOTE CONF
So we need a grammar that takes that option away
from us and forces us into the right option.
NOTE CONF
So, um, well, let's talk about this Here.
Uh, ambiguity comes in two forms, uh, precedence and associative.
NOTE CONF
Well, you solve ambiguity in two ways.
Precedence and associative precedence refers to whenever I've got different
NOTE CONF
operators, which one should take precedence over the other.
And I'm just talking about operators here because we're dealing
NOTE CONF
with expressions.
But later on, this is gonna apply to everything in
NOTE CONF
the language.
Uh, when I've got two operators, which one takes precedence
NOTE CONF
over the other.
So plus and divide, you know which one takes precedence
NOTE CONF
to divide If you get two property.
If you get two operators with the same precedent, all
NOTE CONF
of the same operator right next to her and you're
trying to pick between them can't use precedent anymore.
NOTE CONF
So you use associative instead.
So precedent is a fixed set of rules.
NOTE CONF
This one's more important, and this one's more important than
this one.
NOTE CONF
So is a set of rules, uh, a rule that
says when you don't have precedent, go left to right
NOTE CONF
or right to left, and that'll deal with it.
You could just do right to left all the time,
NOTE CONF
have everything on the prec, left to right all the
time, and have precedents, everything on the same level.
NOTE CONF
But maths doesn't do that.
And we won't do that either.
NOTE CONF
We we put the two different levels in, and ultimately
you can take all of this away by putting parentheses
NOTE CONF
in because parentheses have the highest precedents of everything, and
they just resolve all the ambiguity for us.
NOTE CONF
But we wanna write programmes where people don't have to
put all the parentheses in.
NOTE CONF
We just do.
Uh, it's hard to explain when you've just got little
NOTE CONF
expression examples.
But if you takeaway persons and associative and force people
NOTE CONF
to be unambiguous all the time, you end up with
lisp, and it's, uh, a bit of a pain.
NOTE CONF
So how would we make that ambiguity go away?
Well, he's got his explanation.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna do mine.
Let's go back.
NOTE CONF
And so this way you get two explanations you can
pick which one's better.
NOTE CONF
So let me expand this one out, even though I
said I wasn't going to Yeah, I know.
NOTE CONF
I don't know why I've got it down at 10
o'clock, but we're already here.
NOTE CONF
So with this one, this is everything starts as an
expression so and the only real option I have people
NOTE CONF
online can't see this, but the people in the lecture
can see the grammar on the screen.
NOTE CONF
I've got an option of literal unary binary grouping.
Obviously, the only one that's gonna work is binary, even
NOTE CONF
though I can't quite see how yet.
And binary is going to go to expression operator expression.
NOTE CONF
So But at this point, I've made a decision that
without even realising it, I could have been doing either
NOTE CONF
this grouping where I was gonna put one plus two
in that top expression.
NOTE CONF
And I was gonna put three in the bottom expression.
Or maybe I did this ex grouping and I was
NOTE CONF
gonna put two plus three in the bottom expression and
one in the top one.
NOTE CONF
I don't know yet.
Um, but I gotta pick one at this point.
NOTE CONF
And so if at this point I pick, say the
first one the one that makes more sense to me,
NOTE CONF
I'm going to end up putting a plus in here.
This expression is gonna go to a single literal.
NOTE CONF
She's gonna go to three.
But this expression is gonna go to a whole Another
NOTE CONF
triple of expression operation operate off and expression right, Because
to make that work Oh, sorry.
NOTE CONF
It's gotta go.
Binary.
NOTE CONF
I missed the binary in the middle.
It's got to go to a oops.
NOTE CONF
It, like, has to go to binary, which goes to
this triple.
NOTE CONF
And now I've got enough spots to put everything in.
So this one's clearly gonna be the plus and the
NOTE CONF
literal one and the literal two.
So the alternative, which I can probably do pretty quickly
NOTE CONF
now that I can see this one was expression to
I'll just write binary to expression upper right door.
NOTE CONF
I know it's a bit dull watching me write things,
but OK, and at this point, I split it a
NOTE CONF
different way.
I made the top one the literal one.
NOTE CONF
The middle one was still a plus, and the bottom
one was expression Operate a Oh, sorry.
NOTE CONF
Binary in between question operator expression that speaks that.
OK, and then that was still a plus.
NOTE CONF
And this was the two and the three, right?
Yeah, the two and the three.
NOTE CONF
So these are my two possible derrel relations.
They led to two possible trees.
NOTE CONF
Um, this tree is gonna come out sideways, but look
like that and this tree.
NOTE CONF
Uh, sorry I made a mistake.
The expression is not directly an expression.
NOTE CONF
It's a literal to expression.
So literal.
NOTE CONF
Two little three.
Ok, alright, so two different derivations and we turn it
NOTE CONF
sideways.
Um, I can see the two different abstract syntax trees
NOTE CONF
inside it, so we agree that one of them is
right and one of them's wrong.
NOTE CONF
We agree.
The first one's right and the second one's wrong.
NOTE CONF
So how do I adjust my grandma to force the
first one and not the second one?
NOTE CONF
So the way to do that is to adjust the
grammar.
NOTE CONF
So the trouble was that I was able to choose
the complicated one Kia.
NOTE CONF
Well, it's more like, Yeah, I was able to expand
out that expression using the complicated expression, whereas if I'd
NOTE CONF
only been allowed to expand that out with a literal
I would have been forced into this rout.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, And so the way we do that in the
grammar, I might just copy it over cos I'm just
NOTE CONF
gonna do this one small change as a example.
If I can find the one that was big, it's
NOTE CONF
all Connolly.
Yeah, Yes, cos good, but bad.
NOTE CONF
Everything's perfect.
Um, so I've just written out my original grammar and
NOTE CONF
I can switch screens so that the the everyone can
do the same thing.
NOTE CONF
So the trouble was back down here when I put
the complicated part under there, I got the right answer.
NOTE CONF
And when I put the complicated part under there, I
got the wrong answer.
NOTE CONF
So I need to make sure that this one is
always a simpler thing.
NOTE CONF
So I wanted to force this to be literal, so
I might consider rewriting this as binary is an expression
NOTE CONF
operator literal, that would work for this example.
But it won't work in general.
NOTE CONF
OK, but this is the idea of what you have
to do.
NOTE CONF
You have to adjust the grammar.
So the only place where the complex recursion in this
NOTE CONF
case can happen is on the side where you want
the parentheses to go, and the other side has to
NOTE CONF
be some simpler thing.
That can't be the full complexity.
NOTE CONF
And the way he goes about doing that in the
lecture in the notes is exactly the way we normally
NOTE CONF
do it.
We introduce a new non terminal.
NOTE CONF
He calls it factor and the factor represents everything smaller
than this so that I can't repeat myself and the
NOTE CONF
grammars always have the complex thing on the left and
the simpler thing on the right, and that forces you
NOTE CONF
into a left associative situation.
The precedence gets dealt with in a similar way where
NOTE CONF
you say I'm gonna have multiple levels of things and
I'm gonna make sure that, um, the higher precedence things
NOTE CONF
always get stuck closest together and the lowest precedence things
get stuck further apart.
NOTE CONF
So that's how you end up with a grammar a
bit like this one, where he's introducing new things.
NOTE CONF
He's introducing a production for his highest assoc, uh, highest
precedence thing equality and his next highest precedence thing comparison.
NOTE CONF
And then he's going down through the other one, not
the other way around.
NOTE CONF
Lo lowest precedence thing up here, highest precedence thing down
here.
NOTE CONF
And then he's adjusting the grammar.
He goes bit by bit.
NOTE CONF
It's better just to see the final one, I think.
Yeah, he's adjusting the grammar so that an expression can
NOTE CONF
no longer just be any old, other binary.
It's gotta be, in the first instance, the lowest precedents
NOTE CONF
thing, because then they'll end up highest in the tree.
We already saw that the lowest, the highest precedents.
NOTE CONF
Things happened first were low in the tree.
So we wanna make sure those ones which are the
NOTE CONF
lowest precedent, appear highest in the tree and that they
have Children with things of higher precedents all the way
NOTE CONF
down to the bottom, where the very highest precedent thing
is, the U is the, uh, unary operators.
NOTE CONF
And then if we did this grammar for that same
thing, we wouldn't have all those options.
NOTE CONF
We'd be stuck with just the option we needed.
So I'll do that trace just to show you.
NOTE CONF
Ah, but he goes through the whole process there in
the text.
NOTE CONF
I wanted to give you an alternate view of that
process here rather than just repeat what he says.
NOTE CONF
So please do read that I'm not like like in
the previous weeks, I've said the same thing is in
NOTE CONF
the book.
But this time I'm giving a different explanation.
NOTE CONF
So once I've switched to that grammar which the people
in the class can still see, But the people online
NOTE CONF
can't my one plus two plus three derivation.
Well, once I hit expression, so For those of you
NOTE CONF
watching online, make sure you bring up the the grammar
at the just above section 6.2.
NOTE CONF
The expression can only expand into an equality That's the
only option I have.
NOTE CONF
And and equality can only expand into a all right.
So there's one extra step we're doing here.
NOTE CONF
UH, it can only expand into a comparison and then
optionally a bunch of other things.
NOTE CONF
So a comparison followed by this thing where he goes,
it's either a not equals or it's a dash, followed
NOTE CONF
by a comparison star.
Remembering the star means zero or more of right.
NOTE CONF
So in this case, my quality is gonna expand to
well, there are no greater than equal twos or dashes
NOTE CONF
in my symbol here.
So there's definitely none of these, um, so I must
NOTE CONF
be just expanding the comparison.
The comparison expands to a term which does the same
NOTE CONF
trick.
It says.
NOTE CONF
Well, I need another term or I'm the greater than
the less than a bunch of things with a term
NOTE CONF
after it.
Zero or more of those I don't have any greater
NOTE CONF
than less than so I'm definitely not on that track.
So there's zero of them.
NOTE CONF
So there was only one.
So the term expands.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
I just I know I went Comparison expense to time
NOTE CONF
term expands to those.
So the term is expanding to a factor this time
NOTE CONF
and a factor is a factor.
And then a plus or a minus, followed by a
NOTE CONF
factor zero or more times.
And now I see I've got something.
NOTE CONF
This looks I'm gonna copy it over one plus two
plus three.
NOTE CONF
Now, this looks like what I've got.
So this one I can make work.
NOTE CONF
This one I'm gonna have the top factor is gonna
be the one there's gonna be two of these, and
NOTE CONF
that one's gonna be plus two, and that one's gonna
be plus three.
NOTE CONF
So I've ended up with just one way to do
the expansion.
NOTE CONF
I was railroaded into that way of doing it.
I do want to comment on one other thing here,
NOTE CONF
actually, which he does comment on, but, um, he hasn't
put it in a nice form for me.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I showed you that we had to take the
double recursion out.
NOTE CONF
We had to leave the recursion only where we wanted
the associative, but down here He's got a slightly different
NOTE CONF
format.
So he's done an extra trick in this book that
NOTE CONF
he does explain.
But I want to explain properly.
NOTE CONF
He's taken a grandma.
I I'll give you an example.
NOTE CONF
Grammar just completely made up.
One A equals, uh, the operator B.
NOTE CONF
So this might be a problematic grammar for us because
it's got the recursion on both sides, and we might
NOTE CONF
convert that into a equals B operator CC equals.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Oops.
So beaming.
NOTE CONF
They should be arrows.
So I gotta get my meditation.
NOTE CONF
Right.
Um and I've left that B.
NOTE CONF
Now, in this case, the equals B MC.
I've confused myself.
NOTE CONF
Where is the back?
So it would be Let me put I'll just rename
NOTE CONF
those expressions because that might tweak my brain again.
Expression is equal to an expression up expression.
NOTE CONF
And then the ops are the pluses or the minuses.
Uh, not going to be fine.
NOTE CONF
An expression is an ex well or a little rope.
And then an up is the plus slash minus.
NOTE CONF
So I converted that into a different grammar where it
was, expression equals expression of time are all expression.
NOTE CONF
There we go.
That's the thing I've been seen and, um, equals that
NOTE CONF
are not cortex.
You can see how hard these conversions are because they
NOTE CONF
keep messing it up.
Um, term and then up.
NOTE CONF
OK, so let me back up and re just describe
what I did there.
NOTE CONF
This is a very simple expression.
Grammar that just does pluses and minuses and literals.
NOTE CONF
And then I did the conversion that we did before
to take out to put in the associative.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and so this was the conversion I did back
when I was taking with out of sociability.
NOTE CONF
Um, and you could do that all the time to
take out assert, And he does in the text, goes
NOTE CONF
through and does that.
But then he does one extra step, which he says,
NOTE CONF
actually, no, I've got this better notation.
Instead of all this little dance around here, wouldn't it
NOTE CONF
just be smarter for me to say that X is
a single X and then as many of these terms
NOTE CONF
as you want back you up expects expressions as you
want, and then I can just do or literal and
NOTE CONF
up equal, uh is plus life.
And he joins these two up by saying that whenever
NOTE CONF
I use this rule, I will group to the left.
And you're like, Oh, OK, that was a nice trip.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but I got a There's a little bit of
a confusion in the book, so I'm gonna try and
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna try and back up and explain it again.
Ambiguous Grandma.
NOTE CONF
Less ambiguous grandma author's version of less ambiguous grammar that's
not quite mathematically correct, but works in his partner.
NOTE CONF
OK, um so this is where this is where programming
language theory exists, and this is programming language practise.
NOTE CONF
And because this book is doing both, uh, that's fine,
but I wanted to just make it clear, um, that
NOTE CONF
he does a little trick with his notation there because
I went, he talks about removing ambiguity, and then you
NOTE CONF
go back to his version, where it looks like the
ambiguity has come back.
NOTE CONF
So I was working out how he'd gotten rid of
the ambiguity, and it was because of the way he
NOTE CONF
implements, uh, this right insight version, which he does a
little bit further down.
NOTE CONF
But this is quite a neat definition of the grammar.
Um, it certainly puts the precedents in there for us.
NOTE CONF
He hasn't done any shortcuts for precedent.
He's made sure that there's a rule for each of
NOTE CONF
the levels to make sure that the precedents are separate.
But is short cutting the associative there by, uh, by
NOTE CONF
an implementation, not trick by an implementation detail.
Well, so let me back it up again.
NOTE CONF
We worked out that we had grammars for generating strings,
and that was good when we wanted to go from
NOTE CONF
string to grammar.
The ambiguity got in our way.
NOTE CONF
The ambiguity came We could resolve ambiguity with two things
precedent and associative.
NOTE CONF
I gave you an example of how to remove the
associative one.
NOTE CONF
Um, I.
I probably should have chosen the precedent one, because then
NOTE CONF
he abandons that option and uses that same trick to
do he use that trick?
NOTE CONF
I just showed you for getting rid of the precedent
for doing the precedent, um, and then rolls in a
NOTE CONF
second trick to get rid of associative.
OK, and now we actually have to write.
NOTE CONF
So all we've done now is take a perfectly good
grammar from before.
NOTE CONF
Well, no, we made We've taken almost perfectly good grammar
and made it perfectly good.
NOTE CONF
The grammar has gone from being able to generate all
of our valid strings to be able to unambiguously generate
NOTE CONF
all of our ballad strings.
And that means we can do both directions now so
NOTE CONF
we can generate strings from it.
Or we can generate original con grammar productions from it.
NOTE CONF
Because the ambiguity is gone.
It's a 1 to 1 correlation.
NOTE CONF
Now, instead of a many to one.
Yeah, cool.
NOTE CONF
So now we're gonna write a programme that goes backwards.
And I really wanted to get across the idea over
NOTE CONF
here by drawing my abstract syntax trees inside my grammar
productions that the abstract Syntex tree is a distillation of
NOTE CONF
the the grammar productions.
The grammar productions are used to get the shape, and
NOTE CONF
then we grab the most important parts and build an
abstract syntax tree out of them.
NOTE CONF
And that's why we don't see a 1 to 1
matching between the grammar productions expression, equality comparison that'll go
NOTE CONF
in.
Yeah, that's why even though our Parsa is going from
NOTE CONF
the token stream back to the context Free grammar and
we've said, Oh, that's an A ST.
NOTE CONF
We don't see a 1 to 1 mapping between them.
He doesn't have a quality in his abstract and texture.
NOTE CONF
He's only got binary he doesn't have.
He does have unary.
NOTE CONF
Um and he does.
Doesn't quite have primary.
NOTE CONF
He's got grouping and literal instead.
So they're related.
NOTE CONF
But not exactly the same.
It wouldn't have been my choice, but I get it
NOTE CONF
from a long term idea.
So we go back to the context free grammar we
NOTE CONF
generate that in the process, we pull out the important
parts to put in the abstract syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
And now we've got everything we need for going further.
So we gotta write an algorithm to do this.
NOTE CONF
Just like we write a scanner.
We gotta write a parser and recursive descent.
NOTE CONF
Passing is the technique he uses.
That's a theoretical concept.
NOTE CONF
But the bottom line is he just implements this grammar
as a bunch of recursive functions.
NOTE CONF
For each one of these, he creates a function, and
the function just calls the other functions.
NOTE CONF
And then when they get to an important part that
they need to put into the abstract Syntex tree, they
NOTE CONF
they output it.
So these these rules, when you got a terminal you
NOTE CONF
match and consumer token, those are the terminals being just
the literals the things that don't have other rules in
NOTE CONF
them.
When you get a non terminal, you just call that
NOTE CONF
non terminals function.
If my non terminal's got a bunch of options, I
NOTE CONF
use a switch to try them out.
If my non terminal's got a star or a plus,
NOTE CONF
I use a wild loop to find them all.
And if my non terminal's got a question, it might
NOTE CONF
or might not be there.
I use an if statement.
NOTE CONF
OK, so now he builds the class to do that
hard work the PSA class.
NOTE CONF
Oh, have I switched over?
Yeah, I have the PSA class.
NOTE CONF
Um, it's gonna take in.
It works on a list of tokens, so we give
NOTE CONF
it that as one of its fields, and it works
just like the scanner.
NOTE CONF
It maintains the list of tokens inside and just keeps
track of where it is in the list.
NOTE CONF
And like I said, you know, he writes a function
for each non terminal, and all it does is call
NOTE CONF
the other non terminal.
So expressions, super easy.
NOTE CONF
Expression is always a quality in our grammar, so expression
just calls a quality function.
NOTE CONF
Equality, however, was a little bit more complicated.
Equality was do comparison and then maybe do zero or
NOTE CONF
more of these other things.
So that's what it looks like.
NOTE CONF
The equality function does a single comparison and then loops
around and does checks for the bang equal or the
NOTE CONF
equal, equal.
And if it finds one of them, it knows that
NOTE CONF
it's in that this loop is valid.
So it it, uh, pulls in another comparison, loops again,
NOTE CONF
pulls in.
Another comparison, keeps pulling in comparisons until it's done.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
And at this point, he realises, Oh, there's an important
NOTE CONF
part of the syntax tree that needs to be output
here, so I'm gonna do it.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna do that one on paper as well
to show you what that means.
NOTE CONF
I'll show you what he's doing.
So let's do a simple string that might get pulled
NOTE CONF
up by this pa.
I'm just gonna keep that on the screen while I
NOTE CONF
draw it.
We're gonna do so we can't quite do the the
NOTE CONF
the the bottom bit yet, but we'll just do a
four equal, equal, equal, equal three.
NOTE CONF
OK, so again, if you're doing this online, uh, keep
the the screen, I've got here on your screen because
NOTE CONF
everyone else is getting that on the left screen while
I oops, hit the visualizer.
NOTE CONF
So this is a string that might get sucked up
by this.
NOTE CONF
So the parser the parser starts by calling expression literally
by calling the expression function.
NOTE CONF
And I'm drawing this in the same way as you
just told me to the derivation.
NOTE CONF
And what does the first thing the expression function do?
It calls the equality function.
NOTE CONF
And what does the equality function do?
It calls D comparison function, and then maybe Coles?
NOTE CONF
We don't know yet, but it might do, uh, find
one of those things.
NOTE CONF
It'll do another comparison.
It'll loop around there.
NOTE CONF
Right?
So guess what the comparison function looks like.
NOTE CONF
It looks like a Y loop while, Well, the next
thing you see is one of these.
NOTE CONF
Suck up another comparison.
But if this fires off because this one's eventually gonna
NOTE CONF
be the four blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, this one's
eventually gonna be the four.
NOTE CONF
And the first one of these is eventually gonna be.
The equals equals three.
NOTE CONF
And the second one of these is eventually gonna be
The equals equals two right we need these to become
NOTE CONF
to be less left associative.
We need these to become a binary.
NOTE CONF
We need this to be the output.
And so that's what you can see in the code.
NOTE CONF
As soon as the loop finds one of them.
The first one, it says, Ah, I just found one
NOTE CONF
of these in the star section.
So I'm gonna spit out when it sees as soon
NOTE CONF
as it sees the first one, it spits out 5843.
You can see that it spits out binary expression operator,
NOTE CONF
right?
Yeah, And then it keeps track of that and calls
NOTE CONF
it expression.
So the clinic grabs the next one.
NOTE CONF
It goes up, I'm gonna spit out another binary expression,
other one right, And we end up with the right
NOTE CONF
tree.
So that's what I mean by his trick of when
NOTE CONF
he's sucking things up in this loop.
The the the fact that he builds the binary straight
NOTE CONF
away there is how he gets his lefter certificate.
But it makes for a really nice system that you
NOTE CONF
can just understand that on a theoretical point of view
or a vague idea and then when you go to
NOTE CONF
make your own.
You can just follow these simple rules, which is, you
NOTE CONF
know, wire it, switch it, match it off we go.
And then he just he keeps playing the same rules.
NOTE CONF
So if a quality was a grammar rule that looks
like this, then a quality is a function that looks
NOTE CONF
like this.
Uh, now, he needed a little function in here called
NOTE CONF
Match Match.
Looks ahead to the next thing to see what it
NOTE CONF
was and then gives you a true or false.
And then after matches run.
NOTE CONF
He had to go grab the previous token because he
matched against it.
NOTE CONF
So he writes the match function notice he's doing the
same trick as before.
NOTE CONF
Where he's advancing this current pointer cos he just like
he was advancing through a character stream.
NOTE CONF
Now he's advancing through a token stream.
Um, he's got to check one that doesn't advance.
NOTE CONF
It just looks one ahead to decide if it's the
right one or not.
NOTE CONF
Um, and then he's got the advanced one, which just
moves the current one along, um, and other bits and
NOTE CONF
pieces that will be familiar to us from before.
Are we at the end?
NOTE CONF
Are we peaking.
What's the previous one?
NOTE CONF
Sure done.
But with them out of the way.
NOTE CONF
And here's him explaining what I just explained about how
the way he builds the binaries is how he gets
NOTE CONF
the left associative.
See the first two bind closer, the next one, the
NOTE CONF
next one.
So then terms is gonna be super easy because, well,
NOTE CONF
a comparison is a term.
So a comparison function pulls in a term checks to
NOTE CONF
see if it's more terms.
If it is, pulls in more terms, then the term
NOTE CONF
rule.
He hasn't put it there.
NOTE CONF
But the term rule said, Grab a factor If the
next thing is a minus or plus, grab another factor.
NOTE CONF
So he does that.
But the other thing to notice here is that, um,
NOTE CONF
the grammar says that Robert, I'm back here putting my
grandma the grammar says all these binary operators cos all
NOTE CONF
all the way down to here.
These are binary operators, um, are coming from different grammar
NOTE CONF
rules.
I need to use the equality rule when I find
NOTE CONF
these.
I need to use the comparison rule when I find
NOTE CONF
these and term rule.
When I find these to make sure I get my
NOTE CONF
precedent, but the abstract syntax tree says I don't care
if it came from a quality comparison terminal factor.
NOTE CONF
If it's a binary, it's a binary.
Like the fact that I've lined them up, left and
NOTE CONF
right is how I've got my association and precedent sorted
in my abstract syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
So all of these are output binary, binary, binary, binary.
So, again, what I said about the abstract syntax being
NOTE CONF
the essence of the grammar.
But it does still keep the structure, um, and then
NOTE CONF
multiplication and division.
OK, so the UNARY operator has two options, and so
NOTE CONF
for that one, he does an if statement.
If it looks like we're about to get a bang
NOTE CONF
or a minus, I must be using the first version
of this.
NOTE CONF
So do those.
Otherwise, I must be using the second version.
NOTE CONF
So do that, and then primary is just a bunch
of ifs to see which one you get.
NOTE CONF
And if you get none of them, you gotta make
sure you get a parenthesis to work.
NOTE CONF
Um, he had some error checking here because on this
one, notice that I can match a false true nil
NOTE CONF
number or left per end.
But what happens if I don't get any of those?
NOTE CONF
So the pasa also has to be able to do
error checking, cos the scanner lets through a bunch of
NOTE CONF
things that the Parsa won't accept, particularly the scanner will
let through parentheses, princes, princes, princes And you'd be like,
NOTE CONF
Well, I can't pause that.
But it was valid for the scanner.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so the PAS has got its own set of
checks.
NOTE CONF
So the errors we were seeing before were scanner errors.
The errors we'll see now are parts of errors, but
NOTE CONF
we've still got to build them all into the error
system.
NOTE CONF
So that's what he does, and we tend to go
syntax Errors tends to be both scanner and Parsa errors.
NOTE CONF
If you remember back at the start, he spoke about
a lot of times.
NOTE CONF
Scanning and parsing get merged into that one phase.
Um, but it's nice for us to think about scanner
NOTE CONF
errors being different to pasa errors.
A scanner error is I don't even know what that
NOTE CONF
symbol is.
It's not even in my language.
NOTE CONF
A pasa error is that symbols in the wrong place
for me to construct this tree that I'm trying to
NOTE CONF
construct.
OK, so he speaks a little bit about what he
NOTE CONF
wants to do with error checking.
Um, one thing he does here is he tries to,
NOTE CONF
uh this parer tries to recover from an error in
a nice way.
NOTE CONF
But this is, uh, a complexity in the Parsa.
If you only want to understand it without the error
NOTE CONF
checking, go for it and then come back to deal
with the error checking.
NOTE CONF
But I'll tell you how he's dealing with the, um
but he's trying to catch up when he finds an
NOTE CONF
error.
So what he does to try and catch up when
NOTE CONF
he finds an error is he introduces a concept called
synchronisation, which is, uh, probably if I get to see
NOTE CONF
one of these tokens, I can probably start parsing again.
There was an error, but this token is gonna kind
NOTE CONF
of freshen things up and let me start again.
You can think of a new line is definitely gonna
NOTE CONF
be one of those characters, right?
Or a semicolon.
NOTE CONF
Maybe this statement's messed up.
But once you see a semicolon, I should start parsing
NOTE CONF
again to see if I can recover and find out
more errors for the user.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise, I can only give them one passing error at
a time.
NOTE CONF
And so he creates these special tokens, he says.
Which of the tokens, um should reset the parser and
NOTE CONF
try again.
And so he says, If I've seen a semicolon, definitely
NOTE CONF
reset.
And if the next thing I see is one of
NOTE CONF
these, then definitely reset.
Um, I just I would just copy and paste this
NOTE CONF
bit for the moment because, to be honest, I think
this should be later when he gets into the statements
NOTE CONF
part, because right now we're only parsing just expressions.
We don't reset anything, right?
NOTE CONF
We never see those.
We we aren't seeing any of those in our code
NOTE CONF
at the moment.
We're only seeing numbers and pluses and operators.
NOTE CONF
OK, so his last thing is just to wire it
up, Um, he creates a PA function.
NOTE CONF
Parsing always starts at the first production of the grammar.
So his first production of the grammar is expression.
NOTE CONF
He introduces a special parser that he can catch, and
then it goes into the, um, the main method.
NOTE CONF
If you recall we already scanned things, we already scanned
things into tokens back in our locks class.
NOTE CONF
Now we take the tokens and we run them through
the Parsa, um, here and that spits out.
NOTE CONF
Oh, it spits out one expression.
Is that what we were expecting?
NOTE CONF
Well, the expression it's spitting out is the the top
of the tree, right?
NOTE CONF
It's It's spitting out a whole pile of expressions in
a big tree, but you've only got to give me
NOTE CONF
the top of the tree, the root of the tree,
and then I can find all the others.
NOTE CONF
So it's spitting out that single top of the tree.
And then he uses the a ST printer that was
NOTE CONF
written last week as a visitor to actually print that
out on the screen for you.
NOTE CONF
So let's see that in action, because I think there's
some interesting things to say here.
NOTE CONF
All right, a lot going on.
Just take it by.
NOTE CONF
I need to give it OK, so let me just
give a a Hitchhiker's Guide to this chapter.
NOTE CONF
The Hitchhiker's Guide is a bit of theory here in
ambiguity.
NOTE CONF
Yes, get your head around that tonnes of marks to
be gained just by understanding my ambiguity discussions and his,
NOTE CONF
um, practise getting rid of ambiguity from grammars because I'm
probably gonna ask you questions about that, Theoretically.
NOTE CONF
Right then.
Practically.
NOTE CONF
And so that's end.
Ended up with this grammar here.
NOTE CONF
Um, I'm very likely when I give you any question
I'm gonna accept.
NOTE CONF
Remember how I said there were the the programming theory
side and then the practise side Both have the ambiguity
NOTE CONF
removed.
I'm gonna accept either of them for when I ask
NOTE CONF
for an unambiguous grammar.
But I am gonna ask you for an ambiguous describes
NOTE CONF
at some point and then into the practise of actually
implementing that in his system.
NOTE CONF
Um, I would spend time and energy on these functions
that are doing the work for us.
NOTE CONF
And I would save your time and energy for the
error checking and the synchronising for later.
NOTE CONF
But I've got all that converted over into my M
locks.
NOTE CONF
So let's open that up.
Because there's a few things to discover about how it
NOTE CONF
works too well.
Interesting things to say.
NOTE CONF
Oh, there we are on the on the screen.
OK, so I did all of that, but I did
NOTE CONF
it within my M locks.
Um, so my expression dot java was my abstract syntax
NOTE CONF
tree and my pasa, which I call impsa.
Oops, not class.
NOTE CONF
Impsa.
Java just did all the things he did, and there's
NOTE CONF
nothing fancy.
And I didn't change anything in there unless I've done
NOTE CONF
some implementation for, uh, the assignments.
Oh, I did copy this in, though.
NOTE CONF
I like having the grammar at the top of the
of the top of the implementation.
NOTE CONF
And because he's got his in a text friendly format,
it makes life nuts and easy for me.
NOTE CONF
I might even put it might even be a smart
idea for me to go through each one, you know,
NOTE CONF
and say like you did in the notes.
Um, quality is the implementation of that rule, and then
NOTE CONF
I can see that that's implemented in the actual code.
And maybe I won't do the same for comparison and
NOTE CONF
so on and so forth.
That's probably a good idea.
NOTE CONF
Uh, then back in my M locks dot java, I
did something a little bit different, so I'll show you
NOTE CONF
what I did.
We've got the run file and the run prompt.
NOTE CONF
Uh, they both called the run method, So the run
method is where the action is.
NOTE CONF
His run method said scan, take a scanner and scan,
build the pas or in PAS.
NOTE CONF
I decided I wanted to see the scanner output and
the Parsa output.
NOTE CONF
So in my run method, I scan and then I
print out all of those tokens just like I was
NOTE CONF
last week.
And then I pause.
NOTE CONF
And then I print out the positives as well, so
I can see better.
NOTE CONF
So if I fire up my M locks remembering that
I've got to to properly do this, I've got to
NOTE CONF
generate the A ST.
Refresh it.
NOTE CONF
Perhaps.
Is it done?
NOTE CONF
Yep.
So that fixed up my expression dot Java file.
NOTE CONF
Then I've got to compile my Java code, and in
my case, I stick it in a jar file in
NOTE CONF
case I need to send it somewhere.
And then I can run my interpreter and it looks
NOTE CONF
like it's already running, So let me fix that.
OK, so down the bottom here, if you can just
NOTE CONF
see.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
I fired up my own M lock interpreter, But But
if I give it one, the scanner runs and it
NOTE CONF
notices a number one in a semicolon and an end
of file.
NOTE CONF
The Parsa runs and it just sees a one.
Um it looks like the Parsa is just gonna go
NOTE CONF
backwards to the original string.
But I, I we've got to show you what it's
NOTE CONF
really doing.
The Parsa is actually in this case generated, uh, a
NOTE CONF
ST that's got a single literal node in it with
the value one inside.
NOTE CONF
So maybe I prefer if that a literal one.
Well, how am I gonna solve that?
NOTE CONF
That goes over in my masked printer.
The mass printer has a different visit for every of
NOTE CONF
the different things it's visiting.
So I am gonna tell it that I would like
NOTE CONF
it to tell me that it's a literal one, not
just put one, so I updated my pretty printer.
NOTE CONF
So when it sees a literal value, instead of just
printing out the value of it, it prints out that
NOTE CONF
it's a literal so that I can be convinced the
pas has done what I wanted it to.
NOTE CONF
So now I have to compile it again.
Um, yeah, contaminate the dip.
NOTE CONF
The pile.
OK, so now I updated my pretty printer so that
NOTE CONF
the scanner is showing me.
It got a number token and an end of file
NOTE CONF
token and the powers that are showing me it got
a literal node.
NOTE CONF
OK, so let's try 12.
So the scanner accepted that 12.
NOTE CONF
The paths are accepted it as well.
Um, it just passed what it could out of it
NOTE CONF
and just passed the one.
The two didn't make any sense.
NOTE CONF
So these paths are actually happily leave leftover bits at
the end of your machine.
NOTE CONF
Your string?
Uh, because we haven't told it that it has to
NOTE CONF
finish up.
So let's do something that's really silly.
NOTE CONF
Oh, can we do?
There you go.
NOTE CONF
So if I just put in the star, the scanner
is perfectly happy.
NOTE CONF
It reads it in as a star and end a
file.
NOTE CONF
But the parser can't do that because it doesn't have
any productions that star with a star one plus two.
NOTE CONF
Now I can start to see the structure that's being
built by the Parsa.
NOTE CONF
The scanner picked up blah, blah, blah.
The Parsa has picked this up as a plus with
NOTE CONF
two Children that are literal.
Now it can't show me a tree notation like I've
NOTE CONF
been drawing cos it's a text window.
So it's trying to show me a tree notation using
NOTE CONF
parentheses.
It's saying, Oh, well, this plus node is going to
NOTE CONF
have two Children and they're grouped together as soon as
I go to a third one.
NOTE CONF
Now I the structure is starting to become visible to
me.
NOTE CONF
The parser is saying, I found two pluses, but the
one I grouped closest was the one on the two.
NOTE CONF
And that's why they're in the parentheses together.
And then the other ones were outside and so that
NOTE CONF
there is the the one line text version The only
way you can describe it in text, really of OK,
NOTE CONF
Uh, well, if you look above I know, you know,
people online can can't see it, but the one plus
NOTE CONF
two plus three but it's showing me so I'll draw
it up here as well where it's showing me.
NOTE CONF
Remember that yours won't put the plus in there or
the literal Yours will just put the symbols cos I
NOTE CONF
changed my pretty printer, um, the one that showed when
I saw this on the screen.
NOTE CONF
That's the text way of showing me.
Plus, with one and two is really tightly bound.
NOTE CONF
And then that one's bound to plus of 3.0.
So it's a way of showing me a tree in
NOTE CONF
a single line of text.
And Damien, can you tell me what's so cool about
NOTE CONF
that single line of text?
He's not paying attention.
NOTE CONF
That's alright.
Um, this way of describing trees in text is as
NOTE CONF
old as the hills, and it's called expressions or something.
And some programming languages let you programme directly in that
NOTE CONF
notation.
And so you're basically programming the A ST yourself, which
NOTE CONF
exactly so.
The point being, though, is that the what you're seeing
NOTE CONF
here is the output from the Parsa is the best
effort it can make to draw those trees in your
NOTE CONF
head.
I want them to be trees, Um, because that's what
NOTE CONF
they really are.
I want you to be drawing out each of those
NOTE CONF
trees yourself because this is much harder to get your
head around until you become a L programmer.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but that's what the parenthesis in his code is
about.
NOTE CONF
Like, where does parentheses come from?
If you read through things, I gotta parenthesize things you're
NOTE CONF
like.
Why?
NOTE CONF
Because the only way to put a tree on a
on a console is by parenthesis, each little triple each.
NOTE CONF
Each thing that's got two Children or more than one
more than two Children.
NOTE CONF
Well, let's try another one.
OK, so there you go.
NOTE CONF
This one's only got one child.
It's the bang operator with the literal two, but it
NOTE CONF
still uses the same trick.
It says I've got a bang operator with a child,
NOTE CONF
so I'm gonna put them in parentheses so I can
tell that this is the head and that's the child.
NOTE CONF
And when I've got the plus operator with the two
Children, I you can see I've got an operator with
NOTE CONF
two Children, all right, trying to work out what I
wanna do next, because I think that's everything.
NOTE CONF
Try.
Synchronising is recursive, so I won't talk about that.
NOTE CONF
I'll probably do something else instead.
OK, cool.
NOTE CONF
So what I think I might do with the rest
of my time depends on what questions I asked you
NOTE CONF
to do thing.
I wrote myself a little note.
NOTE CONF
What does my little note say?
Red Jack says.
NOTE CONF
All right.
OK, so what I thought about I mean, that's all
NOTE CONF
that done.
Boom.
NOTE CONF
Let's lock that off.
If our brains are full, let's just go into this.
NOTE CONF
Remember, I had this mode where we just let waves
wash over us.
NOTE CONF
Um, let's go into that mode, and then let's come
back and watch this part of the lecture again later.
NOTE CONF
Um, but let's make the most use of the time
we've got.
NOTE CONF
What I wanna do is something that takes in all
the parts up to now, which is to make some
NOTE CONF
change to my programming language.
Uh, add a new feature to the programming language and
NOTE CONF
all the bits I'm gonna have to touch to do
that.
NOTE CONF
And the thing I've decided I want to add is
a regular expressions literal.
NOTE CONF
It's might just be a fun thing to talk about
anyway.
NOTE CONF
So this language has let's make a new page.
This language has literals for strings.
NOTE CONF
Oops, Yeah, I'm checking the right thing and number and
new right.
NOTE CONF
Which means those are the only things we can write
down that are values you can think of a lot
NOTE CONF
of other things you might put in.
What other literals do you know of in code?
NOTE CONF
You know of maybe a ra rules and we've got
floating point numbers, but they go under number uh, bullions
NOTE CONF
could be added, I think he added, bulls.
We do have bullions.
NOTE CONF
We got true and false.
So they got bulls.
NOTE CONF
So I was trying to think of What's another fund
literally you can put into your language?
NOTE CONF
I do this lamb as as a literal, uh, lamb
as can't literals Yep.
NOTE CONF
Lamb, as are expressions.
So I thought, What's something we like to use in
NOTE CONF
programming is that some programmings have literals, and that's a
red X.
NOTE CONF
So if you you we must have played with Red
X's before, right?
NOTE CONF
We already talked about Red X's.
Yeah, cool.
NOTE CONF
Uh huh.
But our regular expression is a string that can potentially
NOTE CONF
match other strings.
The general syntax if you want to put them into
NOTE CONF
a programming language.
So you know how strings start with double inverted commas?
NOTE CONF
Well, Red Jack start with a forward slash, and they
end with a forward slash.
NOTE CONF
So if I do forward slash forward slash and then
put some stuff in here.
NOTE CONF
Oh, that's a B plus underscore.
I'm writing a regular expression, and maybe I just want
NOTE CONF
to be able to put that in a variable and
use it later for something that's all I'm.
NOTE CONF
That's what I'm gonna add to my language.
How do I do that?
NOTE CONF
So I'm just gonna step through some parts of that
to help reorient us to this compiler in a concrete
NOTE CONF
way.
So we're gonna do this on my, uh Well, one
NOTE CONF
way to do it is just to try.
And so the scanner has actually read this in as
NOTE CONF
a slash identifier slash um, and the Parsa has thrown
an error.
NOTE CONF
But if I think back to my scanner, should my
scanner be treating a single literal as three separate tokens?
NOTE CONF
No.
We should be treating it as a single token, because
NOTE CONF
that's what we did.
We didn't treat a string as a inverted comma, and
NOTE CONF
then an identifier and then an inverted comma.
We treated it as a string.
NOTE CONF
So I'm obviously gonna have to back up to my
scanner and make some adjustments.
NOTE CONF
The reason it accepted slash already is because slash in
this language.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I was not projecting the right thing for the
online.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
A slash in this language can be a divide symbol,
NOTE CONF
or it can be the start of a comment.
So I've got to find the part of my scanner
NOTE CONF
that checks on slashes.
And I've gotta say, uh, if it's a slash without
NOTE CONF
a space after it, uh, it's a slash, uh, this
is the way things get a bit tricky for me,
NOTE CONF
doesn't it?
Because in my language, uh, equals four slash three.
NOTE CONF
That should be for slash three, but four slash three
a to be should be.
NOTE CONF
Well, what should the scanner do with that?
But it's not unambiguous.
NOTE CONF
What to do with my slashes is the point I'm
trying to make.
NOTE CONF
It's impossible for me to get the scanner to make
a good decision here.
NOTE CONF
So, uh, what can I do?
Well, one thing is I can delay it to the
NOTE CONF
plaza, but I don't wanna do that.
And instead, I am going to use a different, simple,
NOTE CONF
simple as that.
Ok, um, I control the language.
NOTE CONF
Why don't I make it, uh, square brackets could Maybe
if I wanted, I'm actually gonna do I think I'm
NOTE CONF
gonna do that.
Has other meanings in Red Jack.
NOTE CONF
So I don't like it.
Hm.
NOTE CONF
I can just be creative here.
I'll tell you what I'm gonna use a tilda.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna go slash tutor so my rejects are gonna
look like this slash tilda three a two B slash.
NOTE CONF
OK, so they start with a slash tilda and they
end with a slash That still looks enough like a
NOTE CONF
red checks to me that I'm happy and it keeps
my scanner happy as well.
NOTE CONF
You're gonna Once you start writing your own languages, you'll
start to see these decisions that other programme other language
NOTE CONF
designers have made.
Where you're like I just did that to get it
NOTE CONF
through the scanner.
The so the til Show.
NOTE CONF
Oh, yeah, Exactly.
OK, so if I wanted to get this into my
NOTE CONF
scanner, I still have to go find where the slash
is.
NOTE CONF
But let's look for that slash Then I switch over.
So my M scanner is here.
NOTE CONF
We're not gonna get all the way through this, By
the way, we're just gonna be part of this.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so I could either go back and reread my
entire scanner and reread that chapter.
NOTE CONF
And maybe I would if I was doing this for
the first time.
NOTE CONF
But, you know, enough of the scanner is still in
my head.
NOTE CONF
I'm just gonna go looking for where the slash is,
and I find it.
NOTE CONF
But I better better have some memory of what was
going on in the scanner, because I've got to make
NOTE CONF
sense out of these lines here.
But I, I do remember.
NOTE CONF
I remember that, Um, once we saw a slash, we
had to work out.
NOTE CONF
If the next character was a slash I'm in comment
land.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise, I'm in slash land.
So that's exactly what it does.
NOTE CONF
It goes and looks.
Is the next character a slash If it is, then
NOTE CONF
do it as a comment.
Otherwise, just do it as a slash.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna wanna adjust that part so that if the
next character's a Tilda, I do it as a Red
NOTE CONF
Jacks.
Nice.
NOTE CONF
I can do that.
So that's gonna be an LS if match Tilda.
NOTE CONF
And probably I'm gonna do very similar stuff.
Um, comments just get thrown away.
NOTE CONF
So I'm actually gonna put a reds in here.
I'm gonna call the Red Jack function to do the
NOTE CONF
hard work, and that doesn't exist yet, But just like
we did before with where's another one where we quarter
NOTE CONF
function?
See how we used the function string when we needed
NOTE CONF
to do strings and then break.
I'm gonna do that for my red Jack, so I
NOTE CONF
better go write that one.
So I need a red Jack break.
NOTE CONF
No, the brake's already down the bottom.
Now I have to write a red check function.
NOTE CONF
Which of my current tokens is the most, like a
radical expression?
NOTE CONF
Probably an identifier.
So I'm gonna copy what Identifier says.
NOTE CONF
There it is.
And make a red axe out of it.
NOTE CONF
OK, so I close one rejects.
So in this one, it said as long as the
NOTE CONF
next thing is alpha numeric, then advance Pull out the
subs string and add.
NOTE CONF
In that token, I actually want to advance as long
as the next thing's not a slash.
NOTE CONF
So I actually wanna say Wild Peak is not equal
to slash advance and I When I get to the
NOTE CONF
end, I can actually grab the subs String again, just
like before.
NOTE CONF
But the token I wanna add, Remember?
Actually, when we go and identify, we had to check
NOTE CONF
that it wasn't a keyword.
I don't have to do that here.
NOTE CONF
That's not a problem for me.
Um, so I'm just always adding a token.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but the token I'm adding is not an identifier.
I've gotta make a brand new type of token for
NOTE CONF
this, don't I?
Which I don't have yet.
NOTE CONF
So I better go over to M token type.
And I'm gonna add a red Jacks in here.
NOTE CONF
OK, so a tokens not happy because I think I'm
using some text.
NOTE CONF
So let's go double check some other a tokens to
get reminded.
NOTE CONF
OK, so that's where it goes first, the the symbol
goes first, and then maybe some extra parameters go there.
NOTE CONF
So we're going to add symbol rejects with text that
way.
NOTE CONF
Alright, Well, I'm gonna try compiling that to see if
it's gotten me anywhere.
NOTE CONF
I gotta kill this slightly compiled for me, So I
must have got rid of all my compile errors.
NOTE CONF
Look at that.
It worked almost.
NOTE CONF
OK, so I've grabbed one too many characters from the
front and not enough off the back.
NOTE CONF
And so I left the slash there, so it got
consumed by the next thing.
NOTE CONF
I didn't want to do that, So I'm gonna add
one more advance at the end.
NOTE CONF
And when I put the string in, it included both
those two characters.
NOTE CONF
I didn't want, so that should probably be start plus
two.
NOTE CONF
And then I can try again.
So there's a bit of understanding what's going on.
NOTE CONF
There's a bit of experimenting with what's going on Xhosa.
OK, so because I advanced one more current is now
NOTE CONF
not where I wanted it to be, So I gotta
put a minus one there.
NOTE CONF
Alright, Cool.
So now our scanner can generate Red X's.
NOTE CONF
But where is the red X gonna go in our
grammar?
NOTE CONF
So now I'm pleased that I added that into the
Parsa because I've got the grammar at the top, right?
NOTE CONF
Oh, already out of it.
I guess I must have been working on this.
NOTE CONF
It's a surprise.
Both Red Jack just goes in where all the other
NOTE CONF
literals go.
So the primary just needs to be.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna have to adjust this primary function.
So I go find that.
NOTE CONF
So it's matching false true nil number, string or symbol,
which is something I've added for.
NOTE CONF
Maybe it's in class.
Maybe it's in an assignment.
NOTE CONF
I don't know.
And you get a preview?
NOTE CONF
A leper.
Um, so somewhere in here I've got to grab the
NOTE CONF
red es.
It's pretty simple Actually, I just wanna say if match
NOTE CONF
red X turn new federal value is Ah.
So this is why where I need the previous dot
NOTE CONF
literal, uh, pulls out, um, what's inside that token for
me?
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna cheat and just put a N.
I just put a red Jacks here just to get
NOTE CONF
going.
Cos what a literal token here.
NOTE CONF
Sorry, value doesn't go up in programming.
Uh, python, um literals were that tree node.
NOTE CONF
Remember, that tree node just had a value.
So when the literal was false, the value's false.
NOTE CONF
When the literal's fall, the value's four.
When the literals are reds, what's the value?
NOTE CONF
It's whatever value is stored inside that red X, which
is rep, which is discovered by the previous liberal literal
NOTE CONF
there.
But I I'm just gonna do the short list.
NOTE CONF
Well, I've just done a cheap version where I just
make every red es have the string red es in
NOTE CONF
it.
Notice that I'm not having to redo the a ST
NOTE CONF
generator, cos I'm still using the a same a ST.
But if I'd made any changes to my A ST,
NOTE CONF
I'd have to rerun that as well.
Here we go.
NOTE CONF
So now, the, um, Red Jacks is being accepted by
the Panther.
NOTE CONF
I'm sorry.
I only touch a few places.
NOTE CONF
Um, and because I knew what I was doing, I
got there.
NOTE CONF
And if I really knew what I was doing, I
might do a little bit more.
NOTE CONF
Uh, what's the message?
I want you to get out of that little demonstration.
NOTE CONF
Well, first of all, I just wanted you to have
an example of someone going through and making those kinds
NOTE CONF
of changes because they're the kind of changes we're gonna
ask you to make.
NOTE CONF
I wanted to demonstrate how few places you have to
touch as long as you know what's going on.
NOTE CONF
And I wanted to demonstrate kind of the cognitive processes
I was going through as I was speaking about how
NOTE CONF
I was making the judgement that this was the place
to change and what I should be changing.
NOTE CONF
OK, so the goal of watching me do that is
not just to see what I did.
NOTE CONF
The goal of watching me do that is to see
how I did it.
NOTE CONF
Because you're gonna be asked to do the same thing
for different right?
NOTE CONF
And that's something that I think comes back to my
point right at the start of a lecture, which is
NOTE CONF
that we're so used to seeing other people, then doing
what they did as a way of learning.
NOTE CONF
And we've got to transition to seeing other people and
understanding how and why they did what they did.
NOTE CONF
Because we're no longer in the copying phase.
If we were just copiers, noone would be paying us
NOTE CONF
the big bucks.
We're moving to the generalising stage where we take someone
NOTE CONF
else's technique and apply it in a new place.
Alright, I think that's more than enough for today.
NOTE CONF
Thank you, everybody, for your patience.
This morning, I'll put up a poll.
NOTE CONF
If we get more than you actually know.
I've gotta find out who you are.
NOTE CONF
You're the only ones who matter.
Um, I don't know how I can find out who
NOTE CONF
you are.
Um, well, we'll just do one more show of hands
NOTE CONF
now that you you know that something's riding on it.
The lecturer will go to 9.
NOTE CONF
30 if more than half of you put up your
hands, who wants to go to 9.
NOTE CONF
30?
All right, we got a 930 apologies.
NOTE CONF
to those who are happier with nine.
but the traffic's probably gonna beat us in a couple
NOTE CONF
more weeks.
Anyway, one other thing that I was gonna just pop
NOTE CONF
in when you were talking about the, uh, mirror handling
it's worthwhile having a think about when you've been using
NOTE CONF
other Why is sometimes do the error.
That seems to be what the hell?
NOTE CONF
Uh, yeah, it's because the error handling has dropped through
and tried to recover.
NOTE CONF
And that is giving you an error.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
No.
Sensibly.
NOTE CONF
Exactly.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Alright.
We gonna go check out this festival of learning.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's happening right now?
NOTE CONF
I think cancelled, isn't it?
What I Where is it?
NOTE CONF
Uh, the light.
How the hell do you know?
NOTE CONF
Because she's organising it.
No, it's not me.
NOTE CONF
Nothing She was saying.
You saying you organiser organiser No.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, all the game boys.
I need some that.
NOTE CONF
I'm not on your body.
I thank you for me.
NOTE CONF
Let's go.
Um All right.
NOTE CONF
OK, um let's try.
Just give me a sec.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, We, uh uh you're gonna have a a harsh
word with Nick Harrison, the the president.
NOTE CONF
Uh, because they, uh they they put on two different
activities at the same time.
NOTE CONF
The kids, instead of calling No, but